[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport le
magazine est consacrée comme vous le
savez à l'actualité sportive dans le
département c'est parti à pour le
sommaire au rugby prévient enregistré ce
week-end sa première victoire de la
saison dans le championnat de fédérale 2
les plaisirs oies se sont imposés 28 à 8
contre le puc dans un match à sens
unique plus d'informations dans ce
magazine
cyclisme le tracé du tour du tour de
france 2010 9 a été dévoilée jeudi
dernier après où il pour l'édition 2018
0 rouyer qui a été sélectionnée pour
accueillir le départ de la dernière
étape le 28 juillet prochain
coup de projecteur à suivre golfe un
mois après la ryder cup à saint quentin
en yvelines et la victoire de l'europe
l'impact se fait déjà ressentir sur le
nombre de pratiquants dans les yvelines
reportage dans ce à 7,8 sport
l'actualité sportive des yvelines c'est
maintenant sur tv 68
on commence donc par du rugby dans le
championnat de fédérale 2 au stade
robert barran il aura fallu attendre la
7e journée pour voir plaisir valider sa
première victoire de la saison les
plaisirs oies se sont imposés 28 à 8
face au puc
retour sur cette rencontre un montage de
jules grevy lé plaisir stoppe
l'hémorragie après cinq défaites
consécutives dans le championnat de
fédérale 2 les plaisirs en russie a
dominé avec la manière le paris
université club à domicile
le score est sans appel à 28 à 8 sec
il nous faut absolument une victoire il
nous la fallait absolument et je crois
que le monde avait à coeur de bien faire
les choses et défensivement on a su les
agresser voilà quand on avait tous envie
de bien faire les choses et
ça s'est vu ça s'est senti sur le
terrain en tout cas avec cette victoire
plaisir quitte la place de lanterne
rouge et remonte à l'avant dernière
place du championnat à seulement un
petit point du maintien
on est dans une poule qui est très
compliqué nous on est encore tout jeune
à ce niveau-là et du cou et du coup ça
demande beaucoup de travail beaucoup de
sacrifice d'abnégation et voilà et tout
le boulot qu'on met en place depuis la
saison depuis le début de saison
il commence à payer et je crois que
c'est ça qui fait vraiment plaisir on
progresse dans le jeu et dans
l'intensité la semaine dernière à drancy
on doit gagner là bas et aujourd'hui on
a réussi à garder le même niveau de jeu
la même intensité
prochain match pour plaisir le 11
novembre sur le terrain de chartres les
cinquièmes du classement
une nouvelle victoire pourrait
définitivement lancé la saison des
plaisirs war on continue par du football
et le 6e tour de la coupe de france les
yvelines auront deux représentants au
prochain tour de la compétition
versailles club de nationale 3 s'est
imposé sur la plus petite des marges
contre nanterre qui évolue en r2 score
final 1 à 0 autres qualifiés carrière
grésillons les yvelinois ont remporté le
derby contre verneuil-sur-seine à
domicile il s'impose 1 à 0 et deviennent
le petit poucet national de cette coupe
de france c'est terminé en revanche pour
poissy qui s'incline aux tirs au but
contre drancy le prochain tour est
programmé dans trois semaines les
yvelinois connaîtront leurs adversaires
à mercredi prochain on ouvre maintenant
une page cyclisme les organisateurs du
tour de france seront dévoilés à jeudi
derniers les contours du futur tracé et
le peloton passera par les yvelines en
2019 les cyclistes ces lancements depuis
rambouillet pour relier paris le 28
juillet prochain pour la dernière étape
pour nous parler de ce tracé nous
recevons sur ce plateau jean michel
richefort qui est également organisateur
du grand prix de vélizy on en reparlera
un petit peu plus tard dans l'émission
est membre du bureau exécutif de la
fédération française de cyclisme
il sera accompagné down l'ouvrier
champion de france cadet en titre de la
course aux points et nous vient du vélo
club de montigny le bretonneux
bonsoir alors avant de parler plus
spécifiquement de cette dernière étape
qui passera par les yvelines
que pensez vous de cette de ce tour de
france tracé jean michel richard et bien
c'est un tracé
qui va je pense pas morizet les
puncheurs et grimpeurs c'est un tour de
france que l'on peut qualifier de
montagnieu il ya peu d peu d'étapes
réservé aux scream terre mais par contre
dès les premières étapes
on va aborder les vosges avec maintenant
la planche des belles filles qui est
connu et là ça fera une première
sélection après le
le tour de france se dirigera vers vers
saint-etienne puis la traversée du
massif central avec une arrivée à
brioude une étape saint-etienne brioude
qui peut réserver des surprises
après les pyrénées bien sûr traditionnel
avec une arrivée au sommet du tourmalet
où là ça peut faire déjà une première
sélection après le tour remontera par
nîmes
et puis se terminera dans les alpes avec
une super étape et trois cols de hors
catégorie col de vars izoard et le
galibier avec une arrivée à valoir et
puis ce ne sera pas terminé parce que
derrière il ya deux étapes très
difficiles
donc je pense que ce sera un tour de
france très intéressant très ouvert
et puisqu'il faut souhaiter bien coeur
enfin ce tour puis ce sourire à nos
français et quand on part en français on
pense à
romain bardet et puis bien sûr à picot
voilà nos deux leaders
nous allons revenir à cette étape de
rambouillet la 21e de ce tour de france
est revenu
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de cette
dernière étape entre rambouillet et
paris voilà ce sera une étape qui sert
aux sprinteurs pour se montrer encore
une fois sur ces étapes sont dédiés que
au sprint là-dessus il n'y a aucune
chance pour les échappés parce que les
équipes de sprinteurs font un train et
rattrape rang ne veulent pas perdre une
très belle occasion surtout sur les
champs-elysées c'est une surprise ou pas
de devoir rambouillet à nouveau
sélectionné pour cette ultime étape du
tour de france en sachant que
rambouillet avait déjà accueilli la
dernière étape en 2012
non ce n'est pas une surprise la ville
de rambouillet c'est une ville très
sportive qui aime qui aiment le vélo qui
a candidaté bon elle était retenue pour
pour le départ on peut que s'en réjouir
et je pense que rambouillet se
positionne d'ores et déjà comme une
ville candidate pour organiser le départ
du contre-la-montre de l'épreuve des
jeux olympiques donc
je veux dire très heureux de voir
rambouillet villes étapes départ de la
dernière étape du tour le peloton va
passer voir quels secteurs parce qu'on
n'a pas encore le tracé définitif de
cette dernière étape
vous pensez qu'il va passer par quels
secteurs la vallée heureuse le tracé
n'est pas dévoilé d'une façon très
précise mais bien sur le départ
il est quand même la petite idée bien
sûr
on ne peut pas occulter la vallée de
chevreuse avec les fameuses côtes 17
tournant de port royal
je pense que ça sera parti ça fera
partie du tracé avant avant de rejoindre
les hauts-de-seine et puis regagné paris
dans l'actualité un cyclisme également
un grand monsieur est repassé à part les
yvelines vendredi dernier robert
marchand qui soufflera à sa 107e bougies
dans un mois est sorti de sa retraite
sportive le temps d'une petite heure
lors d'un entraînement vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
le cycliste né en 1911 et depuis 2010
est détenteur du record du monde de
l'heure dans la catégorie à master's des
plus de 105 ans avec 22,5 147 km ce
champion était au micro de tv 78 même
âge est bon on peut faire encore quelque
chose mais il ne faut pas se laisser
aller
les jours on vous faisait soyez là vos
fauteuils et bien vous voulez plus vous
êtes foutus taïga mouais je continue
tous les jours tous les jours j'ai fait
un peu de culture physique
bien entendu le s'aliène le plus en plus
dur j'ai attrapé la maladie ou savez ce
que c'est de la mauvaise
donc je savais pas à noter que cette
performance ne sera pas homologué par
les instances internationales les
structures n'ont pas voulu endosser la
responsabilité en cas de problème à
physique
l'incroyable vraiment jean michel robert
marchand ce robert 7 607 dans un mois
107 le 26 novembre prochain
willy robert c'est un phénomène c'est
c'est un exemple un exemple pour nous
tous
et puis il est porteur d'espoir donc et
puis il nous incite bien faire du vélo à
faire du sport et eau
au delà de sa forme physique c'est sa
joie de vivre communicative qui est
vraiment remarquable pour la jeune
génération qu'est ce qu'il représente
robert marchand alors vraiment marchand
il représente l'espoir de continuer le
vélo jusqu'à notre base plus vieil âge
merci pour lui sorti en
quand on s'est dit qu'il ya des jeunes
qui commencent à 15 ans le vélo ça fait
encore 90 ans de vélo s'ils veulent
continuer ça laisse du temps si on veut
si on aime le beaucoup de vélo quand
vous l'avez senti vous vous étiez vorrei
dernier comment vous l'avez senti sur
sur le vélo en pleine forme en pleine
forme et et lorsqu'il lorsqu'il tourne
lorsqu ils pédalent sur le vélodrome est
d'ailleurs il aime en revenir sur ce
vélodrome c'est un métronome il roule
régulièrement à 22 kilomètres heure et
puis il a fallu l'arrêter il a fait 20
minutes après il est descendu une
deuxième séquence de 20 minutes il a
fallu arrêter sinon
et puis lorsqu'il descend bas il est
heureux il est heureux et il communique
sa joie moi je les ai sentis vraiment en
pleine forme
vous le sentez toujours aussi tonique
que lors de son précédent record
il avait réalisé à 22 kilomètres environ
en une heure est ce qui pourrait leur
faire aujourd'hui
oui est exactement de la même façon lors
de son dernier record c'était
2km 575 je pense qu'il était en deçà de
ses possibilités et la moue vendredi
dernier où il tournait régulièrement à
22 kilomètres heure donc bien sûr qu'il
pourra le refaire mais bien je pense que
la sagesse veut qu'il tourne pour le
plaisir sans cette notion de records qui
quand même à son âge il faut qu'il roule
pour son plaisir le plus longtemps
possible
et puis oublié cette notion de record la
question sur robert marchand est ce que
vous comprenez que les instances
hésitent à homologuer ses records parce
que c'est un record dont il monte sur le
vélo oui après il ya toujours un risque
qui dit record 10 public dit médias et
pour un être humain on veut donner le
meilleur de soi même et ce serait
dommage
que une nouvelle tentative
puisse le mettre en difficulté
robert et comme tout cycliste n'est pas
à l'abri d'une chute ce serait vraiment
très dommage donc il est préférable de
voir robert venir régulièrement au
vélodrome pour son plaisir fait faire
quelques tours de piste et puis
descendre du vélo et dire vous allez je
suis en pleine forme alors restez avec
nous sur ce plateau nous allons refermer
cette page cyclisme par un rendez vous
qu'il ne faudra absolument pas manquer
si vous êtes un fan de cyclisme sur
piste le 11 novembre prochain à partir
de 13h le vélotour national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines reçoit le
cinquième grand prix de vélizy avec au
programme de la vitesse du keirin de
l'élimination et du scratch
jean michel richefort vous êtes
l'organisateur combien de pistard
attendez-vous sur cet événement vient
nous attendons une centaine de pistard
bien sûr des jeunes des jeunes juniors
dont erwan qui est le porte drapeau de
cette jeune génération des seniors des
élites avec le champion de france de
demi-fond 2017
il y est clair également des sprinter et
une partie du pôle france sprint avec à
sa tête quand à la fargue quentin
caleyron ryan et la halle où là on verra
pratiquement les les meilleurs français
donc en vitesse par équipes et en kering
sans oublier les féminines où là on aura
un très très beau plateau
féminin et puis du cyclisme artistique
également avec valentine ribes donc tous
les ingrédients sont réunis pour avoir
une superbe réunion
c'est difficile de lire tout ce beau
monde pour un tel rendez vous ah non les
coureurs viennent spontanément parce que
courir au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines pour un pistard
c'est quelque chose d'exceptionnel donc
là ils viennent régulièrement d'ailleurs
toutes les épreuves sont complètes vous
savez qu'on ne peut pas mettre plus de
24 coureurs en piste sur les épreuves
d'endurance et toutes les épreuves sont
complètes d'envoi ne l'avait pas hésité
du tout à participer à cette compétition
je n'ai pas eu de jeu par curiosité
parce que les compétitions des jeux à
domicile à montigny-le-bretonneux déjà
chez eux à domicile donc assez important
de courir ici
mais en plus d'être simpliste l'hiver
elles ne sont pas très nombreuses et il
n'a pas beaucoup en ile-de-france et
sinon faut partir moi donc non faut pas
hésiter à vous êtes entraînés pour
briser le meilleur la meilleure position
possible je m'entraîne pour réaliser la
meilleure position possible bien que
cette course ne soit pas forcément un
objectif pour moi c'est un bon
entraînement pour les courses à venir
donc c'est la cinquième édition est ce
que ce rendez-vous commence à s'inscrire
vraiment dans un calendrier
départemental et même régional matin on
se dit cette date là c'est leurs
privilèges
oui c'est la première épreuve qui compte
pour la coupe d'hiver d'île de france et
après il y a quatre autres rendez vous
donc le deuxième rendez vous le 18
novembre
le troisième rendez vous
le 9 décembre quatrième rendez vous le 7
janvier et la finale de la coupe d'hiver
qui aura lieu le 27 janvier
nouveauté ou pas chaque année vous
apporter des nouveautés sur ce grand
prix de malaisie on essaie d'apporter du
cyclisme artistique le jamais parlé
juste avant le cyclisme artistique
donc c'est une discipline une discipline
officielle de la fédération française de
cyclisme et qui gagne à être connu mais
c'est de faire des figures acrobatiques
sur un vélo et on est notée et c'est
toujours très spectaculaire justement le
spectacle c'est peut-être ce qui est
recherché un grand prix de vélizy il ya
la vitesse je disais précédemment du
keirin de l'élimination du scratch ce
sont des épreuves vraiment spectaculaire
ce sont des épreuves spectaculaires
parce que qui dit piste bien sûr il ya
une connotation sportive parce que ça
roule toujours très vite mais c'est
spectaculaire lorsqu'on voit une finale
de kering ou un match de vitesse par
équipes donc c'est toujours très prenant
la bonne ça fait quoi de d2 van 3000 de
spectateurs c'est ce qu'on annonce à peu
près 2000 3000 spectateurs plus qu'ici
on premiers spectateurs là ça serait
formidable
bon je sais pas si on les attendra mais
bon l'objectif
voilà on tend toujours vers cet objectif
bien sûr d'une chose que d'être dolby le
don de 50 ans qui vit dans le vélodrome
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines ses
impressions déjà devant la piste qui a
15 inclinaison importance 45 degrés
environ dans les virages près les
spectateurs quand ils nous vous
encourage ça fait chaud au coeur
quand on a nos spectateurs à nous nos
fans notre famille mes amis ça encore
plus cool et quand on gagne c'est une
belle impression de la question
rapidement est ce qu'il reste des places
ah oui bien sûr là les cc s'est ouvert
il ya pas de problème y'a pas d'âge
rypien voilà bon via le
le jour j est bien sûr notre objectif
c'est de remplir de la vélodrome mais
pour ça fonctionne et là vous relever
l'autre vous ne serez pas déçus parce
qu'il y aura du spectacle et surtout de
très très bons coureurs locaux
départementaux régionaux et puis avec
des champions de france et et des
anciens champions du monde
merci à vous d'être passé sur ce plateau
aujourd'hui je rappelle que le grand
prix de vélizy c'est le 11 novembre
prochain à partir de 13 heures au
vélodrome nationale 2 à saint quentin en
yvelines
on prend maintenant la direction de
l'île des loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines opération baptisée à sport en
fille a été lancé par le comité
olympique régional depuis 20 ans la
session automne s'est achevée jeudi
dernier environ 100 filles sont venus
chaque jour sur place pour faire du
sport ces jeunes ont entre 11 et 15 ans
et viennent des quartiers populaires
elles ont tendance à s'éloigner de la
pratique sportive à l'adolescence
écoutez ses propos au micro de patrick
jacques de dixmude
on s'est aperçus dans les clubs que la
désaffection des jeunes filles étaient
plus marquée que celle des garçons
particulièrement à l'âge adolescent
puisque les jeunes jusqu'à une dizaine
d'années font facilement du sport filles
et garçons confondus
par contre à partir de 11 12 ans on se
rend compte que les jeunes filles
grandissent forcément au change
physiquement mais aussi art est le sport
et nous on veut absolument que la parité
dans les clubs soient là
fait est que justement le plaisir de
faire du sport soit encore la partie
centrale j'allais dire de leurs
activités périscolaires un mot de golf à
présent la ryder cup 2018 s'est terminé
fin septembre au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines dans une ferveur
golfique sans précédent en france
un mois plus tard l'impact se fait à
déjà ressentir sur le nombre de
pratiquants dans les yvelines
les images de amano varaldo juste
redresser un tout petit peu le club vous
redresser un petit peu le bus
ok mais super allait très bien pas grave
contactez un tout petit peu au dessus ce
samedi 27 octobre thomas 17 ans a décidé
de participer à un cours d'initiation au
golf de saint quentin en yvelines
la raison le sportif a vibré le mois
dernier devant son écran lors de la
ryder cup 2018
j'ai déjà un peu touché au golf mais ça
m'a fait vraiment donné envie envie d'y
aller sinon je répète attendu quelques
mois avant de venir ou plus comme thomas
ils sont des centaines de débutants
avoir testé le golf dans le complexe
depuis la fin de la ryder cup
ça fait un déclic supplémentaires soit
des gens qui regardaient la télé qui
aime l golfe
voilà et canal+ je crois de mémoire a eu
quand même 2,2 millions de
téléspectacteurs donc ce qu'est ce qui
est énorme et donc il ya beaucoup de
gens grâce à cette ryder cup qui sont
venus me voir
et certains n'ont pas hésité à
s'inscrire dans la structure c'est le
cas de marie la sportive à pratiquer le
golf toutes les semaines avec l'aide
d'un coach
aujourd'hui c'est son deuxième court
c'est un geek tiff aussi parce que quand
on a envie on a envie de s'améliorer en
orbite ou temps des tirs et des papes et
d'améliorer nos performances au total le
golfe qui comptait plus de 800 inscrits
a déjà enregistré 100 inscriptions
supplémentaires depuis septembre on a pu
toucher de nouveaux publics que ça ait
de la personne retraitée à des personnes
qui sont encore en train de travailler à
terme le golf blue green de saint
quentin en yvelines espèrent attirer
plus de 1400 adhérents grâce à cet effet
ryder cup
[Musique]
on commence cette page agenda par de la
boxe le boxeur de la team farrugia
d'elancourt gallus coulon et en plaine à
préparation le 10 novembre prochain
celui que l'on surnomme sur tv 78 le
stratège yvelinois va affronter laïd
douadi pour un match de classement dans
son fief à hénin beaumont pour le parler
de cette rencontre nous recevons sur ce
plateau gallus collomb et son coach
tanguy à falloudja bonsoir alors comment
appréhendez vous ce match
gallice ce combat bien comme toutes les
préparations tous les combats en a fait
la préparation qu'il fallait on arrive à
la fin de la préparation donc c'est
plutôt maintenant le poids à gérer je
suis bien montée en puissance donc
maintenant il n'y a plus qu'à attendre
le jour j pour en découdre et revenir
avec la victoire
tang il est bien physiquement gallus
gallus il est bien physiquement je pense
qu'il a toutes ses chances ce combat là
maintenant c'est gagner chez
l'adversaire en train de soi voilà j'ai
plus peur de l'arbitrage que de gaza
saïd un moment et qu'est-ce que tu es
sous l'effet de faire comme comme
exercice sur sur les derniers jours
est-ce que vous avez une stratégie à
mettre en place les deux mines d'or les
deux dernières mises devant la stratégie
et sa gauche et donc
faut le faire reculer il faut pas sortir
de saint cyr voilà et après on va
essayer de le cadrer c'est quand même un
boxeur qui a beaucoup d'expérience en
face de nous donc justement c'est un
gros morceau en phase 1 14 victoires 0
défaite et un nul
vous êtes outsider favori vraiment sur
ce combat oui surtout que c'est chez lui
donc comme disais précédemment tanguy
chez l'adversaire
en tout cas en boxe on part déjà avec
eux avec on va dire un petit un petit
peu un petit retard mais
on y va on accepte le combat parce qu'on
sait je connais ma valeur tanguy aussi
donc on va pour inquiéter le défi parce
qu'on sait qu'on tout est possible à la
boxe est en moi pour la victoire
comment on fait pour passer de outsider
à favori le mans le jour j lors du
combat eh bien je pense que tout se
passe vraiment c'est vraiment dans la
tête que ça se passe
donc parce que sur le papier bien sûr il
est chez lui il à domicile il a pas de
défaite
donc je prends ce qui est sûr c'est
surtout sur la tête c'est quand même une
bonne préparation et que on est solide
mentalement il n'ya pas y avait aucune
crainte à avoir
voilà vous l'appréhendez comment
justement psychologiquement ce combat là
aujourd'hui comme tous mes combats vous
préparez vous au jour le jour bien il ya
la phase tous les jours pour venir à
l'entraînement parce que faut
s'entraîner il ya toujours le travail à
faire parce que la boxe on a beau être
professionnel on en apprend encore tous
les jours on fait même encore des
basiques direct braves en direct bras
arrière ton travail c'est toujours un
travail perpétuel pour assimiler pour
bien arriver un mouvement propre et
faire des bonds ou les bons les bons
gestes quand il faut ce combat c'est un
match important où c'est un match de
deux classements avant tout attendu
alors tous les combats sont importants
alors n'est pas en football on n'a pas
une deuxième chance après c'est assez
dur en plus y'a pas grand monde s'il
veut le boxer surtout en france la
preuve on est parti en espagne en arts
vient avec pas déjà lé pa des chèvres
des gros des gros morceaux là
il a quand même été champion d'afrique
amateur et il fait partie de la
champions d'afrique de la wsb aussi le
combat le plus important et je l'annoncé
qu'on veut organiser son championnat de
france voilà et là je pense que oui là
ça sera le combat du voleur va louper ça
serait faut trouver l'argent
vous êtes obligés voilà c'est une arme
de la guerre mais on veut l'organiser
vous avez à tous deux d'avoir un
championnat de france c'est avec tous
les accros fils quand on se lance dans
la boxe au départ on se lance on sait
pas trop ce que ça va donner mais arrive
à un certain niveau on a fait beaucoup
beaucoup énormément de sacrifices
c'est à dire des choses sans plan les
amis qui sortent les copains et copines
qui sortent cotisant pas parce que tu
sais que tu as un combat prévu qui allie
gènes de vie à voir donc trop sacrifice
font qu'aujourd'hui
celle ci c'est le minimum c'est vraiment
c'est le minimum
vous êtes actuellement un bilan de 9
victoires 10 défaites et un nul
vous avez 28 ans est ce que finalement
ça casse tout ça passe sur les prochains
combats
c'est encore des dates ultérieures
il ya beaucoup de combats l'extraire
séjour pareil donc voilà maintenant
aujourd'hui je pense que ce qui fait
qu'un boxeur plus continuer ou pas il va
avoir déjà dans la dette
physiquement si eux aussi le corps tient
encore la route parce que la boxe ça
pardonne pas c'est pas tu es tout seul
sur le ring il faut faut répondre
présent
donc si le corps suit et que la tête
aussi il n'y a pas de problème il va y
arriver tant guide
je suis persuadé vous on a parlé dix
défaites à ce que vous voyez dans la rue
est ce que vous fabriquez des boxeurs
parce qu'il marque quelque part c'est
tout ce que j'ai à dire et il est bien
sûr moi je reste passionné qui m'a de
chantôme seront ses yeux voire même
champion d'europe rendez vous est pris
merci et beaucoup à tous et de les
passer sur ce plateau je le rappelle le
combat entre gallus coulon et laïd
douadi est programmée le 10 novembre
prochain à hénin beaumont
je vous propose maintenant de prendre le
large dans cette page agenda le départ
de la route du rhum la course qui relie
saint malo à la guadeloupe sera donnée
le ce dimanche 4 novembre
parmi les participants on retrouvera un
certain à louis burton originaire de
rambouillet le skipper veut terminer
dans le haut du classement sur son
bateau bureau vallée dernière génération
qui sera équipé de foils et de nouvelles
voiles l'autre voix sur cette course
l'un de ses amis éric bellion le verset
y est 9e du dernier vendée globe sera à
bord de son bateau comme un seul homme
il tentera de récolter des fonds en
faveur des personnes victimes de
handicap
son objectif il espère avant tout a
terminé à la course 1 et on referme ce
magazine par un dernier rendez-vous en
volleyball dans le championnat de
nationale 3 les féminines de vélizy
recevront
au centre sportif robert wagner l'équipe
de châteaudun ce dimanche 4 novembre à
16h lévisienne sont ultra favorite de
cette rencontre elle occupe actuellement
la première place du championnat alors
que leurs futurs adversaires pointent en
dernière position
si vous voulez assister à la rencontre
l'entrée est libre c'est la fin de cette
émission très belle soirée sur tb 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]